as a passing fish you'd be forgiven for
confusing this frog fish with a mound of
seaweed but it would be the last mistake
you probably ever make as it turns out
the frog fish is a terrifying ambush
predator the spines on this fish act as
a sort of hair mimicking the look of
coral for seaweed but they also kind of
look like Koosh balls from the 90s you
guys remember that in either case it's
the perfect camouflage but hiding is
just the half of it
the frog fish has another trick up its
sleeve
it's gills whatever fish sleeve really
is when in position
the frogfish deploys an ingenious trick
to lure in a meal it is a fish fishing
for fish dude this striped cardinalfish
never sees it coming
it is fooled into thinking there's a
worm and not a deadly trap at the mouth
of a terrifying predator the frog fish
strikes fast swallowing its meal hole
but maybe with a little indigestion
at least it's given it a quick death
geez went down in one fell swoop really
should eat a little bit slower
I mean savor your meal you don't have
time you know if you think about it you
got the frog fish and the Cardinal fish
there are a lot of fish named after
other animals they never named other
animals after fish I want to see like
the fish monkey or like the fish turtle
can't think of any leave us a comment if
you can and prove me wrong
thanks for watching
[Music]